times during your project when you told
people what you were doing they say
fannie lou who
a lot far more than i care to think i i
have to wonder what the schools are
teaching kids in terms of civil rights
history i would get two responses i
would get wow
from the people who knew who fannie lou
hamer was but i would very often get who
and you i quickly learned i couldn't
belittle that question i just had to say
you know tell them a little bit about
who she was so that i view all of this i
view the writing of it and the talking
about it as
education
has there ever been a book written about
her no
there i take that back there have been
several children's books
one children's book by june jordan and
one for let's say junior high
children that came out a couple years
ago but there has never been a
full-fledged adult biography that shows
her place
in the movement and frankly there have
been precious view about any of the
women in the movement
when did she live
she was born in 1917
the youngest of 20 children a
mississippi sharecropper she died in
march of 1977
in the hospital
not more than 20 miles from
where she lived most of her adult life
you say in the introduction that you met
her once right what do you remember
i remember that she filled up a room
that's the main thing i i decided to try
to write the book
after i came back from that trip from
that meeting
with her i met her in 1973 i had gone to
mississippi to do
some
a set of stories on the civil rights
movement what had become of it
i specifically chose mississippi
because
it had
had so much of the violence that had uh
occurred there and i wanted to meet her
i had seen her testify
at the 1964 democratic convention and i
wanted to meet her so i went to her
house on a very
hot steamy
probably july day
and she wasn't well she was frustrated
she was angry but she spent
an enormous amount of time with me
and
i charisma is an overused word but it
applied to her and when i left that day
i came back to washington because that's
where i was working then
and i had lunch i remember it was at the
pecan restaurant
14th and
something or other in washington with
lawrence giott who was one of the people
who had been in jail with her and i told
him
how
incredibly dazzled i had been by her and
he said why don't you write a book about
her
and so that's when the idea was born
and how long did you spend in washington
total in your life well in my life while
i was born here
and in washington dc in the old garfield
hospital yes indeed i was born in
washington d.c
i grew up in
in bethesda and then in chevy chase
maryland i left
washington to go to college and then i
came back here and worked
i would say from 1970
through 78 first for senator muskie of
maine and then for the new house
newspaper chain where'd you go to school
we're in
college oh penn state was undergraduate
in political science and then i got a
master's
in history from northwestern university
we'll come back in a moment to talk
about fannie lou hamer
but i wrote down a bunch of names that
swirled around her in this book and i
just wanted to just to list them very
quickly eleanor holmes norton
congresswoman from the district of
columbia
john doerr former watergate council and
assistant attorney general
stokely carmichael former head of
schnick
pat darien former assistant secretary i
believe of state andy young former u.n
ambassador and congressman hodding
carter former spokesman at the state
department of the carter administration
aaron henry former candidate for senate
i believe in the state of mississippi
john lewis current congressman from
georgia julian bond former state senator
from georgia and host of a television
show and charles evers goes on and on
how come we know all those names and
don't know fannie lou hamer well of
course i would like to think that a lot
of people
do know fannie lou hamer
so
i think if someone followed the movement
at all or was part of it they do know
fannie lou hamer i think one reason
though
is
if they don't know who she is
uh was that she died
in 1977 when the movement was sort of at
its ebb she didn't have someone
like coretta scott king
was to martin luther king to burnish the
memory she didn't have that so that
that's one thing and frankly i think
another reason is that um
a lot of the
women in the movement have not gotten
their due because frankly it's been the
men who've written history and i think
as you get more and more women writing
the history you'll get more of these
stories there any number of women almost
as powerful in terms of
persona as fannie lou hamer and they
haven't had any story told
this little light of mine why the title
that was her theme song
um that was what she sang in any number
of the mass meetings to sort of get
people
fired up to go out and confront the
police dogs or the voter registrars or
or whatever or if people were scared
she'd sing it to uh
calm their fears
uh the other reason i think for the
title this little light of mine is
it really summed up her she
she was a little light she was actually
a pretty big light and she
shone that light
on a lot of the dark places in the
american soul
and so i think there was sort of a
double meaning in that that was her
theme song that was what everybody
recognized from the movement was one of
the things that she sang often and
that's really uh also what she did was
shine her light on a lot of the things
that needed fixing you know one i don't
know what the audience can tell or not
it's one of the more unusual covers
this is matted around here dull black
this is a shiny see the audience can see
that whose idea was this well it was
some genius at dutton who designed the
cover i i
it may say inside the book jacket who
the cover design was with bob we ought
to give that person the credit
by neil stewart right so neil stewart is
the genius who came up with that the
photograph
is by a woman named charmian redding
and the photograph is stunning
it was taken
during the meredith march in mississippi
in 1966
and it was
one of the few days mrs hamer was on the
march she didn't do marches very much
because she had a severe limp from
either a childhood case of polio or
one of her brothers who had been tending
her when she was little may have dropped
or broken her leg and it didn't set
properly it's not clear
which that was but um
she was on the march for a day or so
and i had been looking
um for
a photograph of
mrs hamer with dr martin luther king and
i really wanted in case people didn't
know her
i wanted to place her
with
king so that they know sort of the crowd
she ran with
and
i went
to see charmian reading
to see if she had a picture i i had seen
some other things
she had taken she showed me that picture
and then she said i have another one a
mrs hamer singing and then it was just
the head shot and
that became such a natural for the cover
go back to this photo just a second here
and ask you this is martin luther king
right how old was he then
you know
well let's see that was taken in 1966 he
died in 68 and he was not 40 when he was
shot in this picture exactly and this is
andy young what was he doing then he was
a chief aide for dr king
and so he was always at
king's right hand and with the southern
christian leadership conference and mrs
hamer was a
field secretary for the student
nonviolent coordinating committee and so
she was one of the people who you could
always count on to rally the troops or
calm people down and that would have
been why she was on the march there's so
many connections in here and this is
this was a surprise to me when i saw
this picture and learned about who this
man was because our audience knows
don edwards the congressman from
california who is len edwards lynn
edwards is his son who is now a
judge in san jose
and he was
a law student at the university of
chicago
at the time of freedom summer 1964
and he was one of the volunteers who
dropped what he was doing that summer
and went to mississippi he lived with
the hamers
part of the summer and he wrote some
wonderful reports
that helped
really bring that summer to life because
you could interview somebody now you
know and they could sort of vaguely
remember what
happened but his reports were written at
the time
for the
i think it was for the council of
federated organizations which was sort
of the umbrella group that ran
the freedom summer and he told some very
detailed stories about how
when mrs hamer would
go into a meeting
with
the white summer volunteers it would
show people that uh they were to be
taken seriously and
she just could
sort of grease the skids for so many
things that would get done and she also
had written him a letter before he went
to mississippi that summer telling him
how dangerous
it would be that the highway patrolmen
were not your friend in mississippi at
that point and that
how pleased she was that he was willing
to come but how dangerous it was and for
him to be very careful and he said
she was the most inspirational person i
ever met
and he said he told me
she knew i loved her and that
um
how how truly remarkable he found what
she and the other people in that small
town were doing you've got a map
here in the front of the book and we can
see
on that map you can see jackson down
here and then but up here in this area
where was she born
well she was actually born in montgomery
county mississippi which is just
slightly
to the right as i'm looking at it uh
from the shaded area she wasn't born in
the delta but when she was two years old
her family moved into the delta
and and right outside ruleville which is
on the map and she lived the rest of her
life outside or in
ruralville mississippi which is in
sunflower county the youngest of 20
children
what was her life like
dirt poor is about the
most concise way of summing it up
they
she was the child of sharecroppers
a sharecropper
it means that the it's a farmer who
rents the land
or uses the land of a white plantation
owner and the sharecroppers can be white
or black but they were mainly black
they would rent the land the
plantation owner would advance them seed
and money to get through the summer the
sharecropper would plant the crop
chop the cotton which meant weeding the
crop would pick the cotton and then at
the end of the season they'd weigh the
crop and then figure out what share
that's where the term came from then
figure out what share
the
the worker got well the things managed
to get subtracted a lot from what the
worker got and so what it really was was
a modern-day form of slavery
so at any rate she was the child of
sharecropper and at about six years old
she started picking cotton herself
she
had only a sixth grade education she was
very smart
but
she had to go to work
after the sixth grade and in fact
that's almost false to say that she had
a sixth grade education because
the children of sharecroppers could only
go to school when they weren't working
in the field so that would be about four
months of the year they didn't have
very good teachers they didn't have
books they you know mississippi
basically wanted to keep an uneducated
workforce to pick the cotton
and so she was poor and they never had
enough to eat
she didn't have shoes to go to school no
hot water no working indoor toilet
tonight no shoes as you say and i just i
wrote a bunch of this stuff down
could she vote when she grew when she
became 21 years old
no and that you know i've thought about
that since then um the summer of 1962
i was 21 years old i registered to vote
i think by going to the courthouse or
the post office and signing something
where
montgomery county maryland
she
in the summer of 1962 was 44 years old
wanted to vote had never been able to
vote because after reconstruction in
mississippi
the
state democratic party systematically
disfranchised
barred from voting the black population
because if they voted
then they would share power they would
want better schools they would want
roads paid they would want indoor
plumbing they would want to share in the
system and the plantation owners didn't
want them to share in the system so she
wanted to vote
she
knew that the system was wrong but she
didn't know
anything
to do about it until the summer of 62
when the
young people from the student
non-violent coordinating committee came
to sunflower county
now what was the student nonviolent
coordinating committee right that was a
group that was formed after the
student sit-ins started in 1960 lunch
counter sit-ins that started in
greensboro north carolina and spread
across the south when the young black
students were trying to
get
equal use of
lunch counters
department stores and so forth they had
a meeting then
which
i'm forgetting the date but i i'm sure
it was 1960 which they formed uh
originally dr king wanted them to be a
student branch of the southern christian
leadership conference the group that he
headed
but the students really wanted
independence they wanted to do things
their own way now this is a picture of
james foreman right right here right who
was he he was one of the
directors of snick as it was called by
its initials sncc snick he was one of
the
leading
people in the student nonviolent
coordinating committee bob moses was
another his pictures there and the young
man with the sunglasses over there
charles mclaurin was the lead snick
worker in
in ruralville
mississippi back in those days
there was a lot of talk about snick
people being trained what at the at the
justice department or
you know there was a lot of suspicion
about the communist influence
where their money come from
they uh i mean they were they were the
revolutionaries in the group they were
much more militant than
sclc and kings sclc
the southern christian leadership
conference they were much more
militant they were
in many cases desperate and they would
take the legal help of anyone that would
help them so the national lawyers guild
was one of the few groups that would go
to mississippi and so there was a lot of
red-baiting there was a lot of
call of the group were communist that
were in fact
simply
working for social justice but
it was easy to
tar someone by accusing them of being
communist so snick was accused of
communist ties miss hamer was accused of
communist ties and
no way i mean she
she said she knew about as much about
communism as she would say as a horse
knew about christmas day
she had absolutely she was not an
ideological person she was
interested in civil rights and then
later in human rights but that was a way
people could try to discredit the work
that was being done at the same time
there was a major figure out of
mississippi
the man on the screen right there james
o eastland who was he he was the
senator from mississippi he was chairman
of the senate judiciary committee
he
i mean it fascinated me he was also from
sunflower county so here you had these
two
giants of that time
james o eastland and fannie lou hamer
who lived 10 miles apart in sunflower
county and worlds apart he had
he had gone to several colleges
he had been elected to the state
legislature when he was in his 20s he
had been elected to the u.s senate in
1942
quite young
he had a plantation he had power fannie
lou hamer
roughly the same age
sixth grade education couldn't vote
until she was 44 or 45 years old and
lived in a house with no
indoor working indoor plumbing i mean it
was fascinating to me that these two
people were in the same
county and in fact it didn't really even
dawn on me until i was
well into the project she kept talking
about eastland this and eastland that
and then i finally realized you know i
think that was the spur that helped goad
her to do even more than she did was
that she knew eastland's power over
people and so she really
meant it when she said she was opposing
him and she wanted to bring jim eastland
down and ultimately the work that she
did he didn't run again in 1978 he chose
not to run
because he wouldn't have been reelected
that enough blacks had been registered
by that time
you worked for senator edmund muskey did
you know
senator easton when you worked for him
do you remember seeing him during those
years
perhaps i passed him on the elevator i
don't think so i don't think i ever saw
him
jamie whitton also plays a role he is
still i believe the man with the most
time served in the house of
representatives the dean of the house
right now how does he figure in all this
he was the congressman
uh back in those days
the state's been redistricted since then
he was the congressman
who
was representing the area in which mrs
hamer lived
and in 1964
the
mississippi freedom democratic party
which was organized that year to oppose
the regular democratic party had
a mock election
that they ran fannie lou hamer against
jamie whitten she had also tried to
participate in the primary
and
she
lost obviously
the freedom democratic party i should
back up was an organizing tool it was an
attempt to show people what you could do
how you could get involved so she knew
she would lose she ran knowing full well
she would lose but it was to show people
how to do it
so she ran in the primary and then in
the fall they had a mock election
and in the mock election of course a
number of
the blacks could vote
in the mock election and so she beat
jamie whitton in the mock election no
surprise
so the following year 1965
fannie lou hamer
victoria gray and annie devine
challenged
the seating of the five members of
congress
from mississippi one of whom was jamie
whitton
there's a picture here can you tell us
who these three folks are okay on the
left is fannie lou hamer in the center
is
victoria gray now victoria adams who
lives in petersburg virginia and on the
right is annie devine who
is from canton mississippi
and
mrs adams and mrs devon are still alive
and still very active
did you talk to them for them i sure did
they were extraordinarily helpful and
when did you start writing what did you
start gathering the information for this
book
1989 i had i got to leave from my job at
that time with the los angeles times
i got a rockefeller foundation research
grant and the fellowship of the
university of virginia the carter
woodson institute i went there i spent a
lot of time in mississippi that year
doing interviews
looking at the archives reading the
transcript of the
trial which we can get to in a minute
but mainly to do interviews so i started
i spent
almost entirely that year
doing research because i knew when i got
back to california i could do the
writing
and i had a contract
with dutton so i knew i had that coming
in i got back to los angeles and then i
wrote the book
back in los angeles i would say i spent
all told about three years
on the book but it had been in my mind
for
since 73. why did dutton buy the idea
well i think they knew it was a powerful
story i think they could see the drama
in the
her attempt to vote
her
the meeting in the winona jail which as
i said we should talk about
and the confrontation
with the
president of the united states
in 1964 at the democratic convention and
with the members of congress in 1965 i
think also they probably knew
that by now in america people are
looking for heroines and fannie lou
hamer was a heroine you've written a
couple other books
yeah what was that about
that's about women in the newspaper
business
it's called a place in the news
from the women's pages to the front page
it was published in 1988
and is
now available from columbia university
press
and it was about
where women are in the newspaper
business
how they got there and what still needs
to change
in terms of their further advancement it
was also i also talked about what
difference it made that there were more
women you know writing editing
and assigning the news why did you leave
the la times editorial board
i left because i wanted to write more
books uh i i guess i'd had a taste of
that freedom that wonderful freedom of
being able to go to mississippi and do
research
being able to
sit down at my computer and write what i
wanted to write
i love working at the la times but i've
i love writing books and i hope that i
can keep doing it how long did you work
at the la times i was there for
13 years
how much of a change did you see with
the number of women at the l.a times
during the 13 years you were there
quite a number in terms of the women who
came onto the news staff when i started
on the editorial page
there was i was the only woman
i was
there had been a woman before but i was
the second woman on the editorial page
ever
by the time i left and now they're four
or five so
that's a sea chain there still are not
enough
in the top management in the whole
newspaper business it's not just the l.a
time so women have made the their women
are making it to the sort of managing
editor and middle level but there's
still very few at the top levels harry
belafonte
he keeps popping up in this book what
did he do
well
he
helped finance
a lot of the
snick activities
he would send money he would help raise
money
by virtue of his name he would have
concerts and people would come and make
donation he went to mississippi several
times
and
at some personal risk in 1963 i can
recall he went to greenwood with
cindy poitier
and
and and so they appeared
uh there at least one demonstration i'm
sure he was there more often than that
he also helped
support mrs hamer at times because
she
didn't make much money her husband lost
his job
on the plantation when she tried to vote
ultimately he got a job as a head start
bus driver but it was a a gap of some
years there when they really didn't have
much income and she would not
keep
any of the money that she helped raise
for the movement or would keep very
little of it so every once in a while
he'd send her some money and the
man who runs the
general store there in ruralville would
remember sometimes that she'd get money
orders from harry belafonte and i think
probably at first he couldn't believe
that this was really from harry
belafonte but it became very clear when
she kept coming back with them that
indeed these were from belafonte so he
cashed them for her but
i i remember talking to harry belafonte
about mrs hamer and he
he sang with her some i think
did you ever hear her sing did you i've
heard tapes i did not personally hear
her saying i've heard tapes it was a
very powerful
voice that she had and that's why i went
to see harry belafonte because
one of the most difficult things i had
to do in the book was
figure out how to describe her voice
printed page is
hard to
describe what somebody sounds like so i
decided i would go talk to some of the
people who sang with her harry belafoni
and pete seeger so i went to see
belafonte uh this was not hard duty to
go see
belafonte or seeger who where'd you find
harry belafonte well it took about a
year to get the interview because he's
so busy but finally he was in los
angeles
doing some
work and i went to interview him at his
hotel suite and he could not have been
more gracious
and he
he really he was another one of these
people who loved fannie lou hamer and
wanted to make the time to talk to me
and he particularly told me some of the
wonderful stories about the trip to
africa that they made after the 64
convention
in which
mrs hamer who they had just been
confronting the president of the united
states lyndon johnson
and
when they got to africa
secuture the president of guinea came to
visit them without an entourage and she
just went
because she said we can't get in to see
the president of our own country and the
president of this country comes to visit
us
as honored guests you got to tell the
story about
what happened right before she met the
president oh yes that was the that was a
good one um
then gotten there it was hot now what's
the country again the country's guinea
and i'm if i'm mispronouncing it please
uh i don't want the whole embassy down
on my neck uh
uh
in west africa um
she went they had a lovely villa that
had been loaned by toure
um
and
um she'd gone and take a bath
and so secretary arrives with un
escorted
so harry belafonte went up knocks on the
door says miss hamer
president toure is here oh she said i'm
you're just
funning me you know um i'm i'm i'm not
ready to meet no president
he said you know
he really is here
so
she evidently just got herself out of
the bathtub in a big hurry dried off
threw powder all over and tried to dry
herself off and came
steaming downstairs and indeed nobody
had been playing a joke on her there was
the president of the country
there and he had on apparently a
sweeping
white caftan
and just swept her into his arms
and she
was rarely at a loss for words
but apparently for a few minutes there
she was dumbfounded and this was in 64
1964 in september couldn't get in to see
london johnson right why not
he didn't want to see those uppity folks
from mississippi
he
she had just challenged him
and his selection of a vice president
and his well-ordered convention
and he just didn't want to deal with
chicago
no no no this is atlantic city city
right
i think i think he
you know lyndon johnson never left
anything to chance as we know what
happened with that election he swept
over barry goldwater but he had just
signed the civil rights bill you'd had
all the turmoil in mississippi he did
not want
his coronation if you will i mean he
didn't want his convention he didn't
want any reason for the southern
democrats to walk out
so he didn't want a floor fight
over the challenge to the all-white
delegation and what the
this the black mississippians were
trying to do was get their case in front
of the american people and lyndon
johnson didn't want it on television and
so he sent hubert humphrey to defuse the
situation with the either direct or
implied threat that if you don't take
care of this you won't get the vice
presidential nomination
so there are a lot of little things the
time flies i just want to i want to make
some connections here let this picture
right here and this
woman
is eleanor holmes norton right
when was this taken that was taken in
1964.
and i think eleanor must have just been
right out of law school
then and yale yes yale law school and
she had been working
with joseph rowell
on the
challenge the legal brief to be
presented to the credentials committee
and you if you show the picture again
there's one other woman people should
see the woman on the right with the
sunglasses is ella baker who was sort of
the intellectual guru if you will for
the student nonviolent coordinating
committee she was the one who suggested
to them no don't be an adjunct of
the
sclc do your own
thing and she was also the one
who suggested to them that they really
be grassroots
organizing
rather than top down the way king's
organization was that they were
from the bottom up because if they
didn't when the students left
then
the people wouldn't know any more than
they had beforehand about how to deal
with the powerful people so that was a
that was in large measure ella baker's
idea
two other
kind of non-sequiturs i could only find
jesse jackson's name in here twice where
was he during ole miss he was in chicago
i i can't be positive i'm not quite sure
at some point he was still in college
in north carolina
he went to chicago in the
mid
to late 60s
i think
he was definitely
involved in the 68
convention
it was one of the things that i didn't
have space for during the 68 convention
i think i mentioned
in there that
mrs hamer and unita blackwell and some
of the other people from mississippi
went to jesse jackson's church
and rode through the streets of chicago
and saw the violence of the anti-war
demonstrators but
jackson
jackson's life touched fannie lou hamers
often
but
i just had to make some hard choices and
really deal more with the people who
were directly working in mississippi the
now deceased first black member of the
supreme court thurgood marshall's name
comes up once and it's in connection
with
harold cox right right
the story uh is told this would indicate
ethan's
power and his attitude
harold cox was had been his have been
eastland's roommate i think in either
law school or college he wanted cox on
the
federal court and lyndon johnson wanted
thurgood marshall
on
the i
wasn't the supreme court then or was it
a solicitor general i can't remember i
think it was i think i think it was
supreme court so he said uh ethan
apparently ran into bobby kennedy at one
point on the hill
and he said and please forgive me my
friends he said if you tell um
the president
senator eastland saying yes this is
boy this is where the memory plays
tricks whether it was john kennedy it
may have been john kennedy appointing
marshall as solicitor general uh we need
to look on this
and i should know this i wrote the book
after all
but
nonetheless
it really doesn't matter because it was
what eastland said you tell
i i'm thinking he said you tell your
brother
that uh if he gives me here i'll talk
i'll give him the [ __ ]
meaning thurgood marshall
uh
i'm but i've got the page number i'm
going to go try to find out
i i think before we end this
and we've got some time we ought to talk
about winona
and but go back to um
when did fannie lou hamer make the first
public move
that made you know that started this
whole process
it was the late summer of 1962
after the student nonviolent
coordinating committee
people had come to sunflower county they
held a meeting they told people what
they could do
if they
would register to vote it made perfect
sense to fannie lou hamer so then they
said this meeting was on a monday night
some things i can remember and other i
can't i was on a monday night and they
said who will go down with us
to the
courthouse on
friday to register she put up her hand
and when she put off her hand that night
i think she certainly changed her
personal history and she changed a lot
of the history for the people who
worked with her and lived around her
they went they made the drive to
indianola they tried to register and of
course the test was there was a literacy
test
and it was geared for
prospective black voters to fail no
matter how smart you were they would
always catch you on something and and if
you didn't fail that part then make you
interpret a sec section of the state
constitution you know state
constitutions they're incredibly
complicated so she failed the test
on the when she got back home that night
thrown off the plantation so that was
when she
the man who threw her off the plantation
really threw her into the arms of the
civil rights movement and it was then
the following summer that she
she'd gone to several meetings to learn
how to train
people to vote citizenship education
they called it she'd been in charleston
south carolina she was on her way home
and that's when she and half a dozen
other people who were on a bus
the winona bus station they were
arrested
then what then what uh
they were the charge was something
trumped up like disturbing the peace i i
always like to say i think they were
disturbing the peace of mississippi
but uh they were taken to this little
brick jail
booked
have you been there i've been there uh i
went to june johnson who was one of the
women who she was only 14 at the time
two summers ago
june took me to the jail with her talked
the sheriff obviously not the same
sheriff that was
in power then talked the sheriff into
letting us see it was an enormous
benefit
they put the people in the cells
i think june was probably the first one
that they
hit with their fists hit her in the
mouth
and hit her beat her
policeman doing this these are policemen
there was a sheriff highway patrolman
and the chief of police uh
then
anil ponder who was sort of in charge of
the group was brought out of her cell
they kept trying to make her say yes sir
she wouldn't do it she'd say yes
not that she was impolite she was
not going to be
humiliated and not going to be
subjected to their
indignities are all the people in the
wynona jail black that we're talking
about yes they're all black
and then
they took um
mrs hamer out of her cell took her to
what they call the bullpen which is
where they kept the male prisoners they
had two black inmates then that they
threatened that they would be they would
be beaten or worse if they didn't beat
mrs hamer they made fannie lou hamer in
this at that point 45 year old
stout short woman who walked with a limp
they made her lie down on the cot and
then one beat her with a blackjack until
he
got tired and then the other one beat
her with a blackjack at the order of the
law officers they break anything uh they
i don't think so she was left with
probably permanent kidney damage
i mean she was
black and blue uh june said if you'd
ever seen a snake's skin it was like
that
after she was beaten she couldn't sit
down for several days they took her back
to herself where i think she promptly
passed out
one of the women who was in the cell
with her said that she ran a fever that
night i mean she had been brutally
beaten
and
they sang to keep their spirits up they
weren't given proper food
and they were in jail for about three or
four days
and
one of the
snick workers lawrence giott came to try
to get them out of jail he was thrown in
jail and beaten
finally
uh andrew young
james bevel and dorothy cotton came up
from a meeting they had gotten the call
that
that's where they were
because when you didn't check in
the snick people would go to work and
try to find out where you were
and so they found they were in the
winona jail
and
they called andy young they also julian
bond was at work in
atlanta he called the fbi so there were
a lot of calls coming into this little
jail
finally on about the third or fourth day
andrew young arrived with bail money and
they
they got out of jail
when they got out of jail
uh
mrs hamer and the rest were told that
while they had been in jail
medgar evers who was the
uh naacp director in jackson mississippi
had been shot and killed in the driveway
of his home
what proof do you have that she was
beaten that badly
well you know i asked the same thing
because i had this horrible thought
supposed the story
was made up the law officers
you know testified in court that the
women particularly had resisted being
put in their cells and they had to be
dragged into the cell
so i wondered about this and i
spoke with the
man who was the u.s attorney
in
oxford at that point a man named h.m ray
he as it happened had been in washington
for a meeting
right after mrs hamer and the rest of
them
got out of jail
fannie lou hamer and the nell ponder
went to atlanta
right after they got out of jail and
they met with dr king he sent them to
the justice department so within let's
say two days after they got out of jail
they got to the justice department h.m
ray was there for a meeting
the
um
somebody said you've got to come and see
this he met these two women he said
there was absolutely no question in his
mind that they had been brutally beaten
there was no way
he saw their injuries he said there was
no way they came from being dragged
across a floor and um there was also a
doctor that had examined them when they
got out of jail but h.m ray was not
a radical he was i mean after all when
you got to be the u.s attorney in oxford
mississippi in 1963. you're not um you
know you're not a sniff worker so i took
his word for it he was a very upright
man by the way just so that everybody
will get the full story
thurgood marshall's appointment as an
appellate court judge in the kennedy
administration was being traded for
harold cox to be a district court judge
and that's on page i won't forget that
again that's on page 13. well i had it
wrong too so it's on page 32. um all
right they were in jail they got out of
jail what got him out again andrew young
had the veil money okay
what happened then was there a trial
there was a trial the following december
lasted about three or four days
it was
right after john kennedy had been
assassinated
so there was no press coverage none none
none you didn't see anything in the new
york times or l.a could not find any
press coverage on this whole incident uh
there was
in the new york times there was a small
story
three or four paragraphs about the
they were suspected to be in jail then
there was a story that yes indeed they
were in jail this came out of the
snick
press operation the julian bond had
gotten this in the paper and gotten on
the wires
there was a story on the front page of
the delta democrat times that
they had been released uh not no word in
any of these stories about that they've
been beaten
the delta democrat times was run by
hotting carter uh it's in greenville
mississippi it was the only paper
in mississippi at that point that
provided uh objective coverage of the
civil rights movement it's interesting
in that story mrs hamer's name was
misspelled it was j-a-m-e-r and so the
first time she gets in the paper her
name's misspelled you know what else is
new
but
then there were some stories that summer
when the justice department brought
charges against
the law officers and the city of wynonna
they brought civil and
criminal charges and the interesting
thing is this was very rare for the
justice department at that point to
bring criminal charges against a
southern
law official it this was before
andrew goodman james chaney and michael
schwerner were
arrested and disappeared the following
summer so this was very rare if it
wasn't the first time it was certainly
one of the first times that this
happened bobby kennedy got personally
involved and announced the charges at a
news conference so that was
in the papers but when the trial came
it was a week after kennedy was
assassinated maybe somebody else has
some press coverage i couldn't find any
and so the trial lasted three or four
days
uh and
all white jury in oxford mississippi all
males yes women didn't serve on juries
at that point in mississippi whole
nother story
the jury deliberated a little over an
hour and acquitted
all the
law officers
acquitted the law officers
what happened to the whole movement
after that what did fannie lou hamer do
from that moment forward well i think
this was one of many cases that made um
the people that were
working in mississippi decide that they
needed help and they weren't getting
protection
black people were dying were being
jailed and beaten and it seemed that
nobody cared so that's when they
brought the
college students down to mississippi for
the summer of 64
and challenged the all-white
democratic party delegation to the 64
convention but that
this was just one element i think that
led them to
bring
the students to mississippi that summer
they
tried to challenge the mississippi
delegation 64. what happened
they lost
they lost but they won
mrs mrs hamer's involvement was she was
sort of the star and witness
their attorney was joseph rau
who was active in the democratic party
who was a national committeeman from the
district of columbia he knew a good
witness when he saw it and he knew he
had heard fannie lou hamer's story so he
put her on the stand and in fact while
she was on the stand in front of the
credentials committee telling what it
was like to try to vote
try to be a first class citizen lyndon
johnson called a press conference in the
white house to try to bump them off the
air
well it was played on
tape or on film that night over and over
so everybody saw her testimony this is
the first time i ever heard of fannie
lou hamer was watching this testimony on
on television she talked about going to
try to vote she talked about
being beaten described it in
great detail she talked about
having shots fired into the house she
talked about um
the threats that she'd gotten and then
finally she said if the mississippi
freedom democratic party isn't seated
then i question america
so it was pretty powerful stuff
and then
she argued against a compromise that
hubert humphrey proposed what they said
they would do is give
the mississippians and come up there
were 68 of them they would give them two
at large seats and they would tell
the
democratic parties and all over the
country that hereafter no one could
discriminate but
and and they said anyone who
will
sign a loyalty oath to the
party's nomination can be seated knowing
very well of course that
the regular democrats wouldn't sign the
loyalty of but at any rate
mrs hamer said
arguing against the compromise because
she said we didn't come all this way for
no two seats because all of us is tired
so
she
the
full convention never knew though that
the freedom democrat didn't want the
compromise it was voted on and it did
become
the
rules of the party and it really did
start opening up the party to the
diversity and overused word now but to
the diversity that we saw at the
democratic convention in 1992. just five
minutes left there's a lot more in here
in this book but let me jump to the end
and we've got some
you've got some pictures here this is a
picture of the funeral what was her life
like
in the last several years
again what year did she die 1977.
her life was i think one of very great
frustration in her last three or four
years she wasn't well
she had hypertension she had a nervous
breakdown at one point i'm sure from
overwork
uh she but she kept on going them it was
extraordinary
um
she
had very poor health care
she developed breast cancer
and had surgery for that in 1976
but she stayed active she
helped bring low-cost housing to her
hometown
she sued the local school system
i helped save the job of the black
principal in the high school there
she
her dream was a farm co-op that would
help people
have food produce their own food so they
could have some independence from the
man and she put it from the plantation
owner she stayed active she
i think five months before she died she
went to jackson for a demonstration
about cuts in medicare
so she
wasn't well i think she
found
mississippi was resisting
the full enforcement of the voting
rights act this frustrated her
enormously so she
uh felt
somewhat abandoned that things were
moving on without her
so she um
i guess
i get sort of sad when i think that she
didn't live to see
the changes that have happened
today she would have loved
i have to tell this story i was in
ruralville mississippi very recently
and at speaking at the public library
that 30 years ago she couldn't use
and
at the invitation of the librarian from
sunflower county
and
a
the new state senator black man named
willie simmons stood up he had defeated
the man who defeated fannie lou hamer in
1971 when she ran for state senate
willie simmons was the first black
senator from sunflower county he stood
up and said
i am living fannie lou hamer's dream
well a pretty powerful moment
here is the
tombstone and you can't see it clearly
on the screen but it says there i'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired uh you
read that a lot throughout your book
where did that come from she
said it a lot she said it to an
interviewer in about 1964.
she would say it
in speeches
all over and she meant it literally i am
sick and tired of being sick and tired
and and and all of the people were tired
of this of course i was
extremely excited last summer during the
1992
democratic convention when bill clinton
quoted fannie lou hamer saying i think
he said something like if like fannie
lou hamer you're sick and tired of being
sick and tired then whatever it was he
was proposing
went on i didn't hear what he was
proposing because i got so excited about
what he said that he mentioned fannie
lou hamer so
you know she is known by
at least certainly a lot of the
southerners who came of age
during that movement what do you hope
this book will do
i hope it will show young people that
one person can make a difference
next book for you
i'm about to sign a contract with dutton
for
a primer on women's history
other books you want to write
yes i'm not quite sure yet
i don't know when i'll get as good a
subject as this again
but i'm sure going to be looking would
you rather write biography or policy
oriented stuff i think right now i'm a
little um
i've been so immersed in her life i'd
like to do some policy stuff until i
find uh
another
this little light of mine
here's what the cover looks like and our
guest has been kay mills
who's now a freelance writer used to be
with the los angeles times editorial
board the name of the book is this
little light of mine
the life of fannie lou hamer thank you
very much thank you brian
[Music]
next week on booknotes our guest will be
alex dragneesh who served as the public
affairs officer at the u.s embassy in
the former republic of yugoslavia he'll
discuss his new book serbs and croats
the struggle in yugoslavia
book notes can be seen each sunday
evening on c-span at 8 p.m eastern time
and again at 11 pm eastern time the
program can also be seen each monday
morning beginning at 6 55 a.m eastern
time
coming up in a moment prime minister's
question time from the british house of
commons
[Music]